-The last few days
of Donald Trump's presidency
have been very revealing.
He has, among other things,
feuded with the press,
admitted that being president
is harder than he thought,
praised authoritarian rulers,
and made bizarre comments
about the Civil War.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As you may recall,
Trump's positions on most issues
during the campaign
weren't all that clear.
But there was one thing
he was very clear about,
and that was that being
President would be easy.
-We're going to make America
great again.
It's gonna be easy.
It's so --
it's going to be easy.
Believe me,
the jobs are coming back, folks.
That's gonna be so easy.
You're going to have
such great health care
at a tiny fraction of the cost,
and it's gonna be so easy.
And they don't understand it.
They said, "But how do you
get them to pay?"
I said, "It's so easy."
And you understand.
Okay? Rely on me.
So easy. That's so easy.
-People
who are actually reliable
don't have to say the words,
"Rely on me."
If you ask our buddy to pick you
up from the airport
and he says, "Rely on me,"
get ready for dinner
at Cinnabon.
Of course,
the story of the first 100 days
has been Trump's
childlike naiveté
colliding with reality.
In fact, Trump has
without shame admitted
that basic aspects of the job
have turned out
to be harder than he thought,
like health care
or China's relationship
with North Korea.
-It's an unbelievably complex
subject.
Nobody knew that health care
could be so complicated.
-Mr. Trump said
he told his Chinese counterpart
he believed Beijing could easily
take care
of the North Korea threat.
Mr. Xi then explained the
history of China and Korea.
Mr. Trump said, and I'm quoting
the president here,
"After listening for 10 minutes,
I realized it's not so easy."
-The president is literally
being tutored
by foreign leaders.
[ Imitating Trump ] And after
he taught me the history
of China and North Korea,
he helped me
with my math homework,
which was very...
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And while
he's at it, maybe President Xi
could give Trump an American
history lesson, too,
because today
when Trump was asked about
his supposed model for
the presidency, Andrew Jackson,
he went on a bizarre tangent
about the Civil War and Jackson,
who died 16 years
before the war started.
-Yeah.
People don't ask that question.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No one ever asked
why was there the Civil War.
And who can forget
those searing letters
from soldiers
on the battlefield?
[ Somber violin music plays ]
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
So Trump clearly, clearly
does not have a firm grasp
on the basic aspects
of being president,
let alone basic facts
about American history.
And now he's essentially
admitting
that he's in over his head,
telling a reporter
that he didn't expect
the the job of President
to be this hard.
You thought the presidency
would be easier
than being a game show host?
There's a reason Abraham Lincoln
is on the 5
instead of Alex Trebek.
Although I have to say
that this,
this is the most absurd part
of Trump's answer.
-I'm a details-oriented person.
I think you would say that.
-No.
I would not say that.
No one thinks details
are your strong suit.
And I'm not even talking
about the little details.
I'm talking about things like
why did the Civil War happen
or, you know, which country
did I just bomb?
-We just launched 59 missiles
heading to Iraq.
-Headed to Syria.
-Yes, heading towards Syria.
-[ As Trump ] Yes. Yeah, Syria.
But you know, Iraq.
Spoiler alert.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Now, you might think --
You might think a president
as unqualified as Trump
would show some humility.
Instead, he spent
the last few days as usual
attacking the media.
Today, he abruptly ended
an interview
with CBS's John Dickerson
after once again making
his baseless claim
that then-President Obama
had him surveilled
but refusing to provide
any evidence.
All Dickerson did was try
to get Trump to explain
what his own words meant,
but Trump was not having it.
-You saw what happened
with surveillance,
and I think that was
inappropriate.
-What does that mean, sir?
-You can figure that out
yourself.
-The reason I ask is you said
called him sick and bad.
-Look, you can figure it out
yourself.
But you stand by that claim
about him?
-I don't stand by anything.
I just --
You can take it
the way you want.
-But I'm asking you because you
don't want it to be fake news.
I want to hear it
from President Trump.
-You don't have to ask me.
-Why not?
-Because I have my own opinions,
you can have your own opinions.
-But I want to know
your opinions.
You're the president
of the United States.
-That's enough. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
-You know, dramatic exits
are definitely less dramatic
when you stay in the same room
and just sit down.
You can't fire me!
I quit!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maybe Trump is just frustrated
by the fact
that despite his many promises,
he has very little to show
for his first 100 days.
In fact, his only real
accomplishment seems to be
turning the Oval Office into
something of a man cave.
A reporter for
the Financial Times
relayed this anecdote from
a recent interview with Trump.
[ As Trump ] No, no, no,
that's not the nuclear button.
The nuclear button
is right next to it.
It's also small and red,
but I remember which one it is
because it's on the right,
and I have the right
to use nuclear weapons.
Of course, I also have the right
to have a Coke
in the middle of the day
because I'm the president
and I don't have to worry
about it the sugar
because I have the best dentist.
I mean, this guy, he is amazing,
and he's right about everything,
which is why I keep
a right button
to the right of my Coke button
that calls my dentist.
You want me to call him
right now?
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
So Trump doesn't seem
to have much knowledge of
or interest in things like
governing or American history.
But there's one thing Trump
is very interested in,
and that's his own
electoral victory
because Trump called reporters
into his office
to discuss the accomplishments
of his first 100 days,
the only actual accomplishment
he had to offer
was the act of becoming
President,
an accomplishment he bragged
about in the middle of a
conversation
about Chinese president
Xi Jinping.
-We were talking,
as I mentioned earlier,
about President Xi
and that relationship,
and then he sort of
interrupted himself
and handed out this map
of the electoral college
and said that these were
the latest figures
of the areas in the country
that he had won in 2016.
And there were three of us
in the interview, as I said,
and he had a copy
for each of us.
I think he just wanted
to relish in the fact
that this map
looks good for him.
And he said,
"The red is obviously us."
And the red are the areas
in the country that he won.
-[ As Trump ] And in fact,
I even colored in
the map myself.
And if you noticed,
I stayed within the lines,
which everyone says
is the hardest part.
And I did it all in under
100 days, which...
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Now, as
troubling as all of that is,
Trump has also spent
a lot of time lately
praising authoritarian rulers
with terrible
human rights records.
For example, he recently issued
a statement
congratulating Turkey's
president
for a referendum that gave him
expansive new powers.
And in interviews
over the weekend,
Trump praised North Korea's
Kim Jong-un multiple times,
calling him a "pretty smart
cookie" and saying...
You'd be honored?
[ As Trump ]
He's very misunderstood.
You'd like him.
We should call him.
I think it's this button.
And Kim Jong-un wasn't the only
authoritarian
Trump praised this weekend.
On Saturday, he spoke with
President Rodrigo Duterte
of the Philippines.
Duterte has been accused
of running death squads
and has bragged that he has
personally murdered people,
like when he said...
It's stories like that
that earned Duterte
the nickname "United Airlines."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Duterte has since claimed
he was joking.
Nonetheless, despite his dismal
human rights record,
the White House
issued a statement saying
Trump and Duterte
had a very friendly conversation
and that President Trump
invited President Duterte
to the White House.
So, if you're a journalist
covering the White House
when Duterte visits,
and you hear Donald Trump
say this...
-Let's give them
a helicopter ride, okay?
-...run!
So to recap, a president
who's in over his head
is fighting with the media,
reminiscing about his
election night victory,
inviting authoritarian rulers to
the White House,
and also maybe doesn't know
why the Civil War happened.
Donald, do you still stand
by your claim
that the presidency
would be easy?
-I don't stand by anything.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪